für mich persönlich
was ist es für ein gefühl auf mehr als
ein menschenleben zurück zu schauen auf
100 jahre begrüße georg stefan troller
bei mir und freue mich sehr dass sie
bereit waren in diesem hohen alter von
100 jahren noch mal wir rede und antwort
zu stehen wir sind uns alle 21 in wien
geboren und schauen auf 100 jahre zurück
was ist das für ein gefühl
komischerweise gewisser stolz als hätte
man drei tore geschossen bei einer
weltmeisterschaft und
eine verblüffung eine verwunderung
wieso habe ich eigentlich dieses
biblische reise erreicht steht mir das
zu verdienen ich das und dann sage ich
mir
sowas ist es
akzeptieren mein leben wie es ist mehr
kann man nicht machen indem ich habe vor
zehn jahren mit ihnen schon einmal
gesprochen
und sie haben auf die frage von mir hat
sich ihr leben gelohnt sind sie
glücklich mit diesem leben damals gesagt
ja eigentlich schon
mit mit vielen zufriedenheit
was man getan hat und mit einigen
hängen bedauern
was man falsch gemacht hat
es gleich zwischen etwa aus
aber gibt es denn wenn sie 100 jahre
jetzt zurückschauen ereignisse die sich
wiederholt haben man sagt ja immer die
geschichte wiederholt sich nicht aber
gab es mal so situationen ereignis und
wo sie gesagt haben das ist so die an
dieser wie das ist so etwas was wieder
gekommen ist er eigentlich nicht
es gab immer schlauer ist es nicht so
jetzt natürlich in dem alter
wiederholen sich die tage und nächte
das ist das
auslaufmodell
aber bis dahin nehme ich habe immer
wieder was neues überraschendes
was beglücken ist und was entsetzen dass
wie in jedem leben das wir gerade
erleben mit einem krieg in europa
sie haben noch den zweiten weltkrieg
miterlebt sie sind als amerikanischer
soldat nach deutschland gekommen und
haben dort unter anderem das
konzentrationslager dachau fotografiert
und haben dann mit soldaten geredet
haben wir noch eine beziehung im
augenblick zu krieg wissen wir noch wie
schrecklich das ist
ich treffe immer wieder leute also
deutsche
mir vermitteln wie sehr sie daran denken
und wie sehr sie das bedauern
ich bekomme die unwahrscheinlichste post
von
68 seiten länge wo leute sich
rechtfertigen oder
mir versichern wollen der 4
in der nazizeit nicht so gehandelt
hätten wie
leiser die meisten deutschen ja
ja das häuft sich sogar mehr leute erst
früher
beziehen sich jetzt auf die
vergangenheit ist eigentümlich man hat
sie abgelehnt man hat sie
verwischt hinter sich lassen wollen
und jetzt
bei vielen leuten stärker als 80 jahren
war das ist eigentümlich kommt dass
durch diesen krieg in der ukraine hat
man da jetzt plötzlich wieder so angst
in europa kann so etwas zu einem großen
krieg werden ja ja
die großen kriege beginne mit kleinen
küchen
der erste weltkrieg begann mit einem
land namens serbien wo die meisten leute
gar nicht mehr wissen wo das liegt ja
wie die ukraine und auf einmal weinwelt
kriegte ich
fürchte dass das auch jetzt passieren
kann
haben wir
diejenigen die heute verantwortlich sind
vergessen wie furchtbar ein krieg sein
kann
naja vielleicht weiß meine leute besser
hält man es 1939 musste aber die
menschliche natur
ist im grunde unveränderlich und
veränderbar und
was die kriegslust betrifft oder
siegeslaune oder wie man das ist
die überheblichkeit der hasch
das ist unverändert das kann jederzeit
wieder hoch flammen wie 1914 oder ganze
das ist
im menschen drin
sie haben als amerikanischer soldat dann
in deutschland 1945 mit deutschen
soldaten gesprochen sie haben bei denen
sozusagen befragungen durchgeführt
in welchem zustand waren die na ja ein
gefangener soldat hat das gefühl ist
alles zu ende ich bin gefangen damit ist
das reich gefangen er
die haben also zumeist ausgepackt mit
ganz geringen ausnahmen
haben alles haben uns alles verraten was
wir wissen wollten und
sie waren
gute soldaten und wohl informierte
soldaten ich glaube weit besser als
unsere
dies oft nur für verkleidete zivilisten
erhalten habe die deutschen bahn
professionelle soldaten und haben sich
etwas eingebildet auf
und
bestand ein
vertrauensverhältnis zwischen
deutschland im krieg das andere länder
nicht hatten ja krieg war leben dass
meine gefühle betrifft so waren sie
absolut in der mitte gespalten
da war mein dasein als
immigrant als verfolgter
opfer
eines
allgemeinen antisemitismus in
deutschland und vor allem in österreich
und
da war die heimat
sehnsucht
das heimweh und
diese deutschen soldaten repräsentierten
die reichmann
auch das ja auch sprachlich richtig
machen aber sie haben sich mit der
heimat nie mehr angefreundet sie sind
nie mehr nach wien zurück gegangen
sondern sie sind dann ende der 40er
jahre nach paris gegangen und leben
immer noch in paris ist paris ihre
heimat geworden oder haben sie immer
noch das gefühl irgendwo gehörig noch
nach wien
darf ich ihnen sagen wer sich vor zwei
wochen auf drängen der österreichischen
botschaft wieder löst rätsel
nationalität angenommen habe neben
meiner amerikanischen
ich habe jetzt einen österreichischen
pass
nach 18 jahren nach 85 jahren ja ist das
ein heimatgefühl in
meinem alter eine gewisse wurstigkeit
aber vor 30 jahren oder so wäre das
lebens verändert gewesen
das hätte mich vielleicht dazu gebracht
nach zumindest eine warme wohnung wenn
nicht überhaupt meine wohnungen mit in
wien wieder auf zu schlagen
die
sehnsucht nach
dem von ihm geliebten wien
und überhaupt das
ländliche streicht das wir ja sehr gut
gekannt haben
war ganz schlag
entgegen dem dass man uns immer diesen
hass zugeschrieben hat den es nicht gab
habe nie gehabt aber auch das land nicht
gehabt und auch seine leute nicht
geschafft
wir liebten dieses lang will liebten
diese stadt und auf einmal woanders zu
wohnen selbst in paris selbst in new
york 23 aufregern städte der welt war
nicht das gleiche war nicht dasselbe als
die heimat also die frage was ist heute
ihre heimat kann ich nicht beantworten
umso mehr als ich
überzeugt bin dass die heimat mit der
kindheit identisch ist
es gibt keine neu erworbenen heimaten
sie haben ihre interviews ihre gespräche
immer sehr stark unter einem
analytischen aspekt geführt sie haben ja
immer von den menschen wissen wollen wie
geht es ihnen wirklich und auf die erste
antwort haben sie immer noch mal
nachgefragt und noch mal nachgefragt das
war zur damaligen zeit etwa in den 60er
jahren sehr ungewöhnlich
dieses ich will das ganz genau wissen
und ich will eine analyse dieses
menschen wissen war das zu beginn so
dass sie das übernommen haben aus der
befragung der soldaten nach dem krieg
hat sie das sozusagen in dieses gespräch
in dieser befragung hineingeführt
naja ein bisschen aber doch nicht so
sehr
wie man vielleicht hätte denken können
der
befragung gefangener kriegsgefangener
deutscher soldaten mit dem krieg
ist eine andere sache als jemanden in
einem kaffeehaus nach seinem leben zu
befahren aber die
unbedingt halt
unverblümtheit
das hin viele auf den kernpunkt
das habe ich wohl damals gelernt
die unbedingtheit das wissen darum dass
man immer noch weiter kann immer noch
weiter fragen kann und dass immer noch
mehr herauskommen kann wenn man es
richtig anlegt ich nehme an dass ich
davon damals etwas mitgekriegt habe dass
mir später nützlich war sie haben zum
beispiel ja mit ganz ganz vielen sehr
prominenten menschen interviews geführt
gespräche geführt und angelo hat sie
wohl mal gefragt wieso sie ihn so fragen
das sei ja wie bei einem
psychoanalytiker also das war schon irre
form menschen zu befragen und mehr
herauszubekommen als bei einem normalen
interview englisch gehört dazu das
individuell meinem häufig stehen der
presse sieht oder sah war ja wie geht's
immer wie geht's stelle immer ja und
essen sie noch so gern schokolade kuchen
wie früher
oder wie man mir gesagt hat fragen noch
nach seiner lieblingsfarbe er war sind
wir jetzt schon morgen also am großen
englischen haut vor
eines meiner ersten ende wird es ich
wusste nicht was fragen und die sagten
ja fragen noch so seiner lieblingsfarbe
oder fragen aber französische oder
englische küche vorzieht ja
das waren die blöden fragen die man zu
dieser zeit stellte damit haben sie sich
nicht zufrieden gegeben sie haben anders
gefragt dabei kamen auch ganz
merkwürdige witzige dialoge
zustande etwa mit brigitte bardot das
ist die berühmte frage die sie ihr
gestellt haben sie haben sie gefragt was
war der schönste tag den sie erlebt
haben sie hat gesagt nein das war kein
tag das war eine nacht und dann haben
sie gefragt was hatten sie an und dann
hat sie gesagt ich hatte nur lippenstift
aufgetragen und das hat sie ziemlich
unverschämt glaube ich ja also mitbringt
bardot konnte man damals
witzige dialoge führen
es macht ihr spaß sie füllte sie nicht
beleidigt
warum weil seine brothers war und eine
gewisse selbstsicherheit dass ihre
erziehung
gewonnen hatte
ein proletarier sohn war aus kleinsten
verhältnissen
und empfang alles was man so fragt er
als zumutung
trotzdem musste ich auch bei dell und
diese fragen stellen und er hat mich ja
auch ganz schön fertig gemacht aber ich
bin auch
haben sie
oftmals den eindruck gehabt dass diese
prominenten menschen ja auch zu einem
großen teil reiche menschen waren
glücklich mit ihrem leben waren ich muss
ihnen sagen das ist die frage sind sie
glücklich nachdem es
junge reporter häufig gestellt hatte
dann absolut ausgeschlossen habe er
seine unmögliche frage die man nicht
beantworten kann niemand kann sagen dass
er wirklich glücklich ist weil den
nächsten moment vielleicht der schlag
trifft ja und weil er doch vor wie jeder
mensch auch furchtbare dinge mitmachen
musste ja also abgesehen davon dass man
dass das herausforderungen schicksal
empfindet zu sagen ich bin glücklich ja
das schicksal schlägt dann sofort zu
als diese frage stellte ich dann nie
mehr und will auch nicht dass sie mir
gestellt wird aber sie haben mit
menschen gesprochen die einen sehr
großen erfolg in ihrem leben hatten
davor kant waren haben sie den eindruck
gehabt dass das ihre laufbahn war dass
sie letztendlich
mit befriedigung auf dieses leben
zurückblicken er wurde
nachdem ich die ersten
30 jahre meines lebens keine ahnung
hatte was aus mir werden könnte nachdem
mein vater immer kopfschüttelnd gesagt
hat was soll aus dem jungen werden
ich bin für nichts ihren nennen eine
begabung zu haben ja
war ich selbst erstaunt über
den zunehmenden erfolg
meiner meiner sendung in meiner filme
und das gab mir eine große sicherheit
und dann noch eine beglückung ja
das ist dafür besonders geeignet begabt
wäre hätte ich nicht gedacht
ich hatte nur komplexe dass ich
eigentlich zu nicht zerteilen kette
waren sie an menschenfreund oder
war menschenscheu und bin ich noch immer
ich musste mich zwingen und alle meine
interviews allem eine befragungen sind
auch selbst bezwungen
ich musste mich hinein
arbeiten
um solche fragen stellen zu können
es ist nicht so dass sie mehr von der
zunge liefen oder
spontan aus mir herausholen
ist das auch eine sozusagen selbst
therapie für sie gewesen dass sie sich
zwingen mussten bei den interviews auch
menschen sehr nahe zu kommen
jaja emigration bedeutet ja auch eine
isolation
menschenscheu menschen misstrauen gegen
andere menschen man weiß nie was mit
einer
ob der nächste mensch dem man trifft
einen hash beleidigt vielleicht wegen
einer ausstehenden religion ob er sagen
wir warum gehen sie nicht zurück wo sie
herkommen und so weiter
ich war
menschen fremd geworden menschenscheu in
der emigration
die armee die 13 jahre soldat hatte auch
nicht ungeheuer dazu beigetragen dass
man
dass man andere menschen
liebte ja
das alles kam ist sehr verspätet sehr
verspätet in meinen dreißigern dass ich
überhaupt anfangen konnte mich wieder
für andere menschen zu interessieren
einzusetzen sie zu lieben
bei manchen haben sie sehr stark
versucht auf diese menschen einzugehen
intensive gespräche zu führen es gibt
ein beispiel
wo das gar nicht gelungen ist zum
beispiel bei woody allen
sie haben glaube ich mal gesagt woody
allen mochte mich nicht und
machte dieses diesen film mit uns nur
weil der spielfilm den er gerade drehte
von einer deutschen firma mitproduziert
war er wurde er war also gezwungen für
deutschland erlebt ein
interview zu geben oder sich filmen zu
lassen aber er hat über einen anwalt von
anfang an
bedingungen gestellt die praktisch
unerfüllbar waren ja alles in allem
dreiviertelstunde zeit und solche witze
her sie haben immer sehr viel gearbeitet
sie waren immer sehr neugierig wollten
etwas neues machen bleibt war sehr viel
arbeit in einem leben vieles private
zurück was man später vermisst
eigentlich nein ich hab's gehabt ich
durfte mit
1000 1500 menschen sollte
seelisch geistig kontakt haben
bin darüber sehr glücklich
und brauche es jetzt nicht mehr und
wären sie so viel gearbeitet haben haben
sie das private nicht vermisst oft weil
er viele machen das liefe doch immer
nebenher
ich habe auch meine frau mitgenommen zum
dreh und so weiter ja aber es ist klar
dass die frauen letzt gls sich
zurückgesetzt fühlten wenn man dermaßen
aufging
in der in eine
personenbeschreibung wie die sendung wie
hieß und die frauen
fragten sich dann wann
interessierte sich für mich entsprechend
offen hat sie das manchmal geärgert dass
sie sich unter druck gesetzt fühlten von
einer frau die sagte jetzt bin ich mal
dran
es macht die sache schwierig ja
alle frauen
die nicht dem gleichen beruf sind
es sind eifersüchtig auf die hingabe mit
der der mann sich andere menschen
zuwendet anstatt ihnen
das haben sie aber nie bereut
doch
es war
der totale
einsatz um nicht zu sagen hingabe für
einen anderen menschen über zwei wochen
länger hat in der regel dauert manchmal
viel kürzer ja natürlich nachher noch im
monatsschnitt aber
diese intensität des zusammenlebens
dass vereine
eine beglückung
eine
selbstbestätigung
die mir
ein selbst zufriedenes leben erst
ermöglicht hat diese möglichkeit sich
an der menschen
hin zu geben und ihre hingabe
herauszufordern
ist das schönste was es gibt auf der
welt und auch das zufriedenstellend und
das einsamste ja
selbstheilung über andere steht nicht
erfreut aber er in der bibel
das war mir vergönnt der ansicht musste
erst den weg finden
aber china gesehen manchmal gefunden hat
wenn jetzt hier ein junger journalist
ein junger kollege sessel würden sie dem
sagen mach das so wie ich oder mach es
auf keinen fall so wie ich
finde deinen weg
er kann es nicht so machen wie ich es
gemacht hat
er muss noch seine art machen
seine eigene neugier befriedigen seine
instinkte
ausleben mit anderen menschen ja
vielleicht hat der anderen menschen dann
musst du dein hass ausleben
oder sein misstrauen oder
welche vorurteile immer haben möchte
ich konnte es machen als roller
beziehungsweise ich konnte herausfinden
was das bedeutet
es wird roller zu machen
das hat
aus irgendeinem grund funktioniert
entgegen meinen erwartungen
sie haben eben davon gesprochen
dass sie jetzt noch einen
österreichischen pass bekommen haben
und wenn man in
einem gewissen alter ist nicht in ihrem
alter sie sind so viel älter als man
normalerweise wird dann hat man immer so
das gefühl es gibt so eine nostalgie
gegenüber der eigenen jugend man
verdrängt die nicht so schönen dinge und
ist ein bisschen sehr stark bezogen auf
die eigene jugend und kindheit können
sie das nachempfinden
ja ja
ich sage ja immer
man soll seine eigene jugend kind heißt
und auch die dummheit seiner jugend und
seiner kindheit nie verachten denn da
rauskommt dann das alles was nachher
kann das was bei mir nachher kam kam aus
der tiefe innersten
überzeugung ich möchte
realität in meine realität verwandeln
das habe ich immer gespürt
hatte keine ahnung wie man das machen
dachte ich würde dichter werden oder so
was ja aber
die die realität
sich zu eigen zu machen so etwas zu
verwandeln das einem selber entspricht
ist ja vielleicht unsere hauptaufgabe in
diesem leben oder unsere einzige
möglichkeit der selbst beglückung oder
selbstrettung und
dass mir das gelungen ist
dank dem fernsehen das ja damals neu
erfunden war das dafür bin ich unendlich
dankbar
sie haben gesagt
da muss man dann irgendwann ankommen und
das ist eigentlich auch einen bezug zur
eigenen kindheit sind sie jetzt mit 100
jahren dort angekommen wo sie hinwollten
angekommen ja
empfinde er so auslaufen
angekommen weil ich da sagen wir mal vor
zehn jahren ja
jetzt
die dankbarkeit dass man noch sei es
dass man keine schmerzen hat das dass
man die schlechten todesängsten windet
dass man noch
verhältnismäßig viele freunde hat das
der
liebe im spiel ist ist doch das beste
was einem passieren kann sie haben ja
mal eine große reportage gemacht liebe
in hollywood
und sie haben gezeigt wie
oberflächlich so etwas sein kann
haben sie das andere erlebt nämlich das
wirklich essentielle an liebe
ich weiß nicht du bist so eine frage
beantworten kann
ja ich bin ziemlich nahe gekommen mir
hätte ich damals gewusst was ich heute
weiß wäre ich der sache noch näher
gekommen
ich hätte das alles besser machen können
man versteht dann
vieles aus seinem eigenen leben selber
nicht mehr
wieso man das und das getan oder gesagt
hat ist einem unverständlich geworden
auch das muss man hinnehmen
es halt ein teil davon
überhaupt
hinnehmen
ist alles
das in viel von der ganzen sache
dass man lernt
sich
die umwelt das leben der schicksal zu
akzeptieren
das ist nur normal
die sogenannte weisheit es leichter
mit der man sich abzugeben hat in meinem
alter
es bleibt viel bedauern
bleibt viel
ärger über
dinge die man getan oder gesagt hat
und es bleibt viel verwunderung
wie viel
gutes anständiges oder zumindest
interessant wird man noch geschaffen hat
wird der welt
georg stefan troller
[Musik]